with the people that left there were
people that also remained and these were
people who would like once a month Linda
I know you're taking time up for
yourself I respect your your thing what
you're doing just letting you know that
I'm I'm sending you love so once I was
ready to go back and be on socials and
be around people those small group of
people I'll say about 10 to 15 were the
people that I kept really close to me
because they understood my boundaries
they understood what I was doing and
interestingly enough they were all kind
of like working on themselves as well 10
to 15 people yeah that's a lot so so how
many I know you want to go into the 98
how many was that how many people was
that so that was extended family because
I needed to focus on self people on
social media that I don't know because
there was a lot of things that I used to
do on socials people hit me up in the
DMS and it was too overwhelming for me
on Twitter and on Instagram and I was
like I can't do this I can't deal with
this anymore
so how many people was that
do you want to go look at my socials
both Twitter and Instagram then you can
work it outfit so what did you used to
do
sorry I apologies I need to know okay so
between 20 2012 to 2016 I ran my own
Publishing Company
produced four magazines glossy titles
everything independently myself and my
partner at the time
left that got into the workforce and
everything and then I've always done
things to do with like podcasting like
I'm here now today or like filming I
used to do active stuff like extras like
I was in Holby City for a bit like as an
extra I've always done creative things
so along the way I've met tons of people
who remember me or remember my
interactions those are the bulk of the
people who are on my socials and support
me or whatever so yeah
so and those are the people that were so
toxic you you cut them off
well I told you about a toxic
relationship last year that I got off so
therefore I decided to cut off 98 of
people okay there's two different
including people like this why what
should be the People You Meet actually
those were the people on my socials that
I felt were quite overwhelming because I
didn't want to always respond to their
DMS and at that point boundaries were a
bit shaky for me
sorry
I've got something to say okay
do you just feel like you just wanted
space yes because I felt I couldn't like
I couldn't bloody breathe yeah I think
the short of it is
you just wanted space yeah you wanted
time for you yeah you didn't want to
really be dealing with a lot of people
or be so you had selective few people
that you could deal with yeah and other
than that you just wanted your space
yeah I think it's more that like
sometimes we just need space like not
every day you want to talk to people no
of course especially you know what I
mean a massive fan not every day you
wanna not every day we want to be happy
sometimes we want to get up we're pissed
off did someone say that you can't you
can't feel it you said you can't fully
heal right or something along them lines
or am I reaching yeah someone said that
all right cool now I said sometimes you
probably can't fully heal all right cool
so do the training but there's still
tiny little elements of you that are
still gonna happen
I'm guessing most of us have heard that
saying if it's not a blessing it's a
lesson cool so for me healing is like
when you can go through a situation and
be like it's not affecting me no more
I've learned yeah it's not like because
I get that what baggage is like for
example if someone broke your trust in a
previous relationship
you're going to move that you might move
that to another relationship but it's
how you move it there's a difference
you're paranoid now
which you didn't get the blessing you
know I mean I mean you didn't get the
lesson out of that or you can be a bit
cautious which is a normal reaction so I
feel like you can heal in it it's just
about how you doing how you deal with it
giving it enough time I know enough
people that get out of a toxic
relationship give it a month they're in
another relationship yes and you're like
what are you doing you're still dealing
with your problems that's because they
don't know how to
stay single like some people they they
have these strong needs to be in a
relationship to fulfill that void that
they feel so maybe you can heal properly
just a lot of people don't do it the
right way yeah exactly I can't
articulate why but when I hear people
talk about healing it just sounds like
nonsense and I can't I can't articulate
why do you know what I get what you mean
but I can't so personal it doesn't look
yeah it's about perception and I get
what you mean though I do so it's like
it just sounds like okay like you're
gonna do one person one person was alone
for six months one person went on a trip
one person yeah I like it what you mean
though I don't yeah we don't really care
about hearing about no heat no but it
depends though like if you're dealing
with someone already
but you get me and I'll find the thing
that's that's healed already
why'd you want to be out here putting
pluses on people all the time
that oh so
two percent of people how does that make
you a better girlfriend in six months
has nothing to do with a relationship it
had everything to do with me and how I
felt for my mental health well I'm just
thinking like from the guy's point of
view so I'm like yeah that's not
something I'll just run into a
relationship and be like oh so by the
way I'm healing obviously
you're not gonna scare anybody I'm like
he knew from what can you'd be surprised
but you know what I just realized men
don't say their healing I've never heard
a man say well that's because
well no I think I think men like women
kind of dramatize things like I think
we're kind of more dramatic like it's a
bit dramatic to cut off 98 of people for
six months it worked for me yeah I mean
I'm not saying I don't I don't know you
I don't know what's but I'm just saying
like men are like okay I took that
element move on yeah yeah
they'll either go and say oh I had a to
heal in my whole face or I had to heal
and cut everybody off or I had to heal
like this this 90 of the time I do feel
like healing is an excuse or a cover-up
for I'm about to go wild right now which
is I mean like that's what Jada that's
what Jada Pinkett women yeah oh yeah I
mean I mean what did what did Jada say
on on the red table talk she said it's a
season of healing and that's like the
like that sounds nuts
and what did she do she screwed uh her
daughter's drug addict friends yeah she
said she was healing him yeah she was
eating him she wouldn't even heal the
herself though she was eating yeah
everything but it is about perception
though to an extent in it because it's
like my healing can be different to
everyone's healing
but that's like confusing because a lot
of times girls will use words and like
we can't even agree on what they mean
yeah so it just kind of comes off as
like nonsense to men but it doesn't
matter because it matters to human it
makes sense to you what I'm saying when
you're communicating to other people it
does matter that they can understand you
yeah you need to yeah
there's that but I think we need to it's
both ways though I feel like like if you
wanna let's say you're only healing to
no alcohol not only your healing Aid to
better yourself as an individual and B
to then be ready for another
relationship because be around others
yeah exactly so yeah I get like in that
aspect any of like yeah that's nothing
yeah but it's just it's just when we say
healing a lot of times there's no
nothing tangible that anyone could say
you're a better person now than you were
six months ago it's just like oh some
time has passed I didn't talk to people
or oh I went on a vacation or oh I went
I rode the see what are they called it I
would disagree I
um was in a relationship for quite some
time anyway it didn't work out as these
things sometimes do and I got really
angry and I got really aggressive at
this person and I was heartbroken and
then I had to take a while for myself to
realize actually a lot of that the red
flags were there but I